grew up in a really small town in Alabama and my sister was and is to this day a
remarkably beautiful woman and I was always really good in school so it fell
into this pattern with my family where people would say things like she's the
beauty you're the brain and among my almost anorexically petite friends
growing up at five foot five a hundred and forty pounds it was universally
acknowledged that I was a fat one the whole thing really started in first
grade I have to say there was a weigh-in in school my best friend Ann Coley who
was going to go on to become the head cheerleader of our high school hopped on
the scale and weighed 45 pounds but when I jumped on the needle cropped it creeped
up to 50 and I looked over and I could see Nan looking at me in horror not just
for me but for herself and she suggested right then and there that go on a diet
and so I did for the next 20 years I would never wear a bathing suit without
putting a t-shirt over it first I would never change at a sleepover party
without getting in the sleeping bag I would never let a lover see me naked
with the lights on and not once did I ever stand in front of my closet to pick
out an outfit with any other intention other than to look as thin as possible
now along the way well-meaning people tried to help but just made things worse
such as my stepmother the Baywatch extra who decided when I was 11 yeah 11 years
old she said to give me a makeover but the result was something like if you put
blue eyeshadow and frosty pink lipstick on a cabbage patch kid it wasn't good
but somehow I managed to get through high school and college and at age 26 I
packed up my baggage and moved to Southern California where surprisingly I
actually got better there was something about like all the just extreme views
people had about their body all the fake everything and the bleach blonde hair
that made me kind of give up I think I kind of I think I kind of threw in the
towel and so I joined a gym down the street because it was cheap and I
discovered that lifting weights could be actually fun because you would get
strong and then with my newfound muscle tone I put on shorts for the first time
ever and went for a hike which led to a run and then when food was no longer the
enemy I started cooking healthy food and after six months I actually lost 20
pounds and one day I was getting dressed to go out and I actually glanced in the
mirror which of course I usually avoided and I realized I almost didn't recognize
myself and I examined myself from head to toe standing there in my bra and
panties and discovered that actually couldn't lose any more weight and I
actually looked pretty darn good now around the same time my boyfriend was
back in Boston and he had decided to produce an independent film and he was
begging me to come back east and produce the film for him but in order to do that
I calculated that I was gonna have to raise $2,000 over the next four months
somehow extra which my $11 an hour temp job really wasn't gonna produce so I
went out and got a copy of the LA Times and as I was perusing the ads for like
you know Chuck E. Cheese night manager and you know evening legal secretary
work I saw an ad that said dancers wanted earn up to $500 a night now you
have to understand I cannot dance I'm somewhat famous I'm my friends for
having tripped over my own feet when I was in college in Boston and actually
knocked myself unconscious on the sidewalk it's true so I ignored it and
went to the other ads but I kept coming back to it like $500 a night so I threw
you on the newspaper and I ran to my room and examined my butt carefully in
the mirror like could it be that my butt was good enough and I picked up the phone
and made an appointment with a woman named Samantha now my best friend Steve
was very against this he said Catherine your newfound self-esteem has been too
long coming and too hard one for you to risk it all because some bitch down at
the strip club doesn't think you're good enough and I knew he was right but I
somehow couldn't stop I just had to see so the next day I put on my sluttiest
outfit and made my hair huge and put on like all the makeup I owned and I went
down and as I walked into the club the most beautiful woman I've ever seen to
this day was pulling herself upside down naked up a pole with grace and I was
like what am I doing but just then I heard someone say you must be Renee now
Renee was a totally insane alcoholic legal secretary that worked with and I
was think I was hoping to channel her so I picked that as my fake name and I said
yes I'm Renee and I thought that there was gonna be all these questions and I
had memorized this detailed like personal history that was all a lie but
she just took one look at me and said when can you start so while I wanted it
in my head I was thinking like no way I was like how about Monday and she said
okay over the weekend I went out and bought a brand new pair of silver
panties and a silver push-up bra and these really amazing silver high heels
and Steve was still trying to talk me out of it he was like Catherine the
smarter the stripper the more they hate stripping what are you gonna do when
some asshole comes up to you and says hey you're pretty hot do you want to give
me a blowjob afterwards in the parking lot you're gonna want to tell him to
fuck off but what you're gonna have to do is go well I'll get fired if I do that
they'll be fantasizing about it the entire time you're on stage I'm on stage
and he said do you think you can do that and I was thinking you know for $500 a
night maybe I can so so so insanely that Monday morning I actually went to work
at my temp job and so at five o'clock I got off and showed up at the club
wearing my tipping outfit which was these very baggy awful black pants a
little sailor top my hair very straight and my glasses and as I walked in I was
told to go over and tell the DJ what my song would be and I walked around I was
like hi I'm the new girl I'll be dancing to Alanis Morissette and he was just
like all right and he says the dressing rooms over there and I looked at the
dressing room and suddenly I realized that behind that dressing room were
probably ten drop-dead gorgeous women and I was like oh my god and so I looked
at the door and I looked at the door of the club and just then I heard hi you
must be the new girl I'm Chloe and that turned into my right was this little
Patricia Arquette sort of knockoff girl and she was wearing stars on one boob
and spangled on the other and one of the 70s styles bikinis with a little silver
skirt and she was adorable she's like I'll show you the way so Chloe grabs me
by the hand drags me off and leads me into the dressing room and I start
getting dressed for the other girls and actually the other girls were pretty
nice and so they explained to me the rules of the club which I hadn't known
before in the first place the first song you did you know in your bra and panties
and little whatever you wore after but the set and they're like the only the
second song is topless and I was like the second song is topless I think I
think the whole time I've been pictured that would just go out on stage and
flip around and let the very end I dropped my bra and run but now you had
to be topless for an entire song and I'm like oh no but I was like okay and like
they're all looking at me I can't back out so like I'm taking off my clothes
and everybody's just naked and so just then I'm the DJ who was just what you
know 300 pound man named Rudy comes into the room and he says and he's like who
girls now the girls are kind of and I didn't even care and and I realized at
the time that maybe I'd gone somewhere that never been before mentally and
maybe I was gonna get through this night so Rudy leaves and I'm starting to go
to the girls go no you can't wear those silver panties you have to wear a G
string and I was like oh no I don't have a G string well bye bye bye but
Janae was this leggy blonde from Texas whose claim to fame was that she's
stripped into her six month of pregnancy Janae says hi I just washed mine here
you can borrow this and she throws it at me I'm like all right so I'm putting a
strange girls G string and I put it on and so the girls um helped me do my hair
and they make a huge and they put on my makeup and like fake eyelashes and all
this stuff and I was ready to go and as I walked out I glanced in the mirror and
I have to say that I looked unbelievable so so so I go out and I go back out to
Rudy and I'm like hi I'm ready for my song and he looks at me and he's like
holy shit box all that was under there and I was like thank you so then Chloe
starts giving me a tour of the club and as what she's doing this this guy comes
up to us on crutches he claims he even shot in a gang fight and he comes up to
me and he goes you're pretty hot you know I'll put you in a music video if
you'll give me a blowjob after the show and I'm like Steve you know and Chloe
says you grabs jumps back and screams fuck you she's a stripper not a goddamn
whore and I was just like nice nice so then I'm so then we walk back out and
and it's horribly the beautiful woman from like the audition day was out on
stage again and she was incredible dancer and she's running around and I'm
just like oh my god but so I couldn't tell Chloe I'm like you know I'm really
a little nervous and she goes no no no you'll have no problem she's like it's
not the best dancers that make all the money it's the girls you can really
connect with the men you can look from guy to guy to guy and make the guy think
that they're only looking at them and it's really not being about a dancer
they just want to see you nude up there but the biggest problem you're gonna
have is that you're gonna get bored no being bored was not something that
occurred to me as it was gonna be a problem she's like no you know you have
a special trick it's called the drop and roll so what you do you know as you go
out there and you sort of like slowly slowly slowly slowly lower and then
slowly slowly slowly roll around she's like the picture you rolling around in
their beds and then slowly slowly slowly slowly stand back up and if you do it
slow enough it could take up like two minutes and I was like great so I go out
and so then Chloe has to do her song and I go and I sit down near the door and I
get a coke to drink because I didn't want to drink alcohol because I had to
drive home like I'm such a nerd and so I sit there and I'm all of a sudden like
it was a really cold night and the wind blew in and I got really cold of course
I hadn't eaten for like three days because I was so nervous you know kind
of like today and so I was like I started to freak out and I looked up and
I was just like what am I doing and so I go over to Chloe who's come off stage
now and she's sitting next to mr. shot and the lead guy like they've made up
now they're friends again and so I go over and I'm like hi you know I was a
you have been so great and thank you so much but I just realized that I can't
dance so I'm gonna go home and practice and I'm gonna come back and Chloe looked
at me right in the eyes and she said if you walk out of that door right now you
will never come back and you'll regret it for the rest of your life and I knew
that she was right and just then mr. shot in the lead guy reaches out like
under the little dress somewhere and grabs my bare ass and he sort of
squeezes it and he slaps me in the ass and he says you know this is the worst
you feel this is the worst thing that's gonna happen to you all night and he
smacks me goes now get up on that stage and I was like all right
and so so I went out on stage and you know it's all went out and I walked over
there was a pole and so I sort of swung around the pole and like Chloe's running
around getting everyone to yell and scream as your very supportive friend and
so like I'm running around and I'm but and then all of a sudden insanely I run
out of things to do and I'm like the drop and roll so I'm like lower lower
lower lower lower lower roll roll roll and as I'm really right I feel something
hit my cheek and I'm like oh my god I'm so bad they're throwing napkins at me
and I turn my head to the right on stage and I opened my eyes and I saw that it
was a dollar bill and I was like and so then I'm like lean back like this and I
see standing above me is mr. shot in the you know gang fight man and he's standing
over me with a roll of ones pulling them off and dropping them down on top of me
and all I could think was I swear to God was what would my ophthalmologist
father back in Alabama think if he could see me right now so um but then like
everyone was throwing money and it was amazing and so I got up and then it came
to finally be the dreaded topless song so I went to the special topless part of
the stage and the song started and I unhooked my bra very slowly and slowly
the strap and slowly the strap and then I let the bra drop to the floor and I
stood there in front of a hundred and fifty people wearing only a g-string the
whole crowd went nuts and I have to say it was one of the most amazing moments
of my entire life no one in that club gave a shit when I made them at SAT no
one cared that was a straight student no one cared that was in the gifted class
when I was eight if they just wanted to see me nude it was so cool I never went
back to the club after that night in the first place security was pretty lax Chloe
kept making like little passing marks okay Chloe Chloe kept making remarks
about how only a few of her friends have been killed by customers which I found
disconcerting but the worst part was at the next day at work walking across the
Sony lot I suddenly was examining every strange man that passed me I was
noticing them and checking them out and I've always been one of the any seem
kind of yucky to me I was sort of it's like every man was suddenly a customer
and I've always known those women that really loves men and I thought if this
is where I'm like after three hours what am I gonna be like after three months or
three years but several good things came out of it in the first place one of the
customers taught me this really cool trick which is the guy is pawing you you
hold his hand because he thinks you're holding his hand but what you're doing
is you're holding his hand off of you this came in super handy the next
summer in my career as a film producer but the best thing of all is that to
this day anytime I'm having a fat day or I've just broken up with someone or I'm
just feeling a little down about myself all I have to do is open the door and
peek into the back of the closet where I still keep those silver high heels and I
know in my heart that everything is gonna be okay thank you